okay quite an interesting press
conference there Gillian because they
try to get into a few little specifics
factual issues that perhaps they thought
would be immediately persuasive to their
case and perhaps there might be bias
with one of the complaining witnesses
that had had a case that was in front of
Judge more cited that named that
particular individual who had already
previously said there was no you know
contact beyond that point but then
nevertheless a divorce proceeding was in
front of him but overall what did you
make of the tone antenna I think you
should call a press conference when you
have new information to present to the
public when you have something new new
evidence new information you don't call
a press conference to essentially
announce that you're going to hire a
handwriting expert which as far as I can
tell is what this press conference
achieved so I really don't understand
the point of it I think it is not the
case request and a yearbook request
which you could do via an email a letter
a fax every you don't have to get you
know the masses involved in that I think
the problem with this press conference
is that you know the handwriting is to a
certain extent on the wall already we
don't know whether judge Moore is guilty
or innocent of the claims for which he's
been accused but either way I think this
bodes poorly for the party that he
elected to serve I think that this
creates major problems for the GOP going
forward for the rest of this year
legislating and then going into next
year winning new seats because he is
embroiled the party in this debate over
sexual assault of minors what
constitutes it if it's okay sometimes
and the whole thing I think renders the
party incapable of governing right now
and this is something that he's brought
single handedly and I don't know that
this press conference goes any great
distance to try and make things better
for him or for the Republican Party yes
well there's a difference between being
defiant and being a dead end er I'd say
read the room Roy your times over he's
no money anymore no endorsements no
thank you was this a response to Sean
Hannity's 24-hour ultimatum I don't know
if everybody knows this but Sean gave
more 24 hours to come up with any
convincing evidence to justify why
you're staying in the race and why you
are not guilty of any of these
accusations and like you said they came
out with handwriting analysis but they
don't even have the analysis no they're
just threatening to get it exactly
perhaps this may have bought the
campaign a little more time I don't
think much more time they're trying to
attack the credibility of Gloria L read
Gloria Allred's credibility in Alabama
is here nationally is here but they're
trying to persecute Gloria Allred and
that's their strategy I don't know if
that's an effective strategy we're gonna
find out but to say that she had no
contact with Roy Moore and then maybe he
presided over a divorce
seems a little ticky tech but
technically accurate and then the
yearbook thing you know I've been seeing
the whole thing over the internet and I
kind of blew it off and maybe this
raises more questions did Gloria Allred
help her forge the thing I don't know
but this is again this is a small part
of the larger picture of women coming
forward teenagers and other people on
the record and saying that Roy Moore was
inappropriate many many times and many
years ago so you're knocking down maybe
one allegation but there's a whole host
of other allegations and they didn't
address any of them and didn't even take
any questions yeah which I thought was
the wrong move PR was well I mean you
don't yeah but you don't even put
yourself up there and to ask these
questions unless you're gonna have some
specific some answers but they're
running out of time because it's such a
compressed time frame and there's so
much pressure mounting I mean they got a
little bit of a break because the
president didn't make a statement about
it but you know one what I think back on
doing and working on so many campaigns
is not only do you do opposition
research you know on your opponent you
do it on yourself and you see what else
is out there you hire the best to be
able to do that to make sure that you're
properly vetted so things like this
don't happen and it seems to me with the
amount and even the quantity of
allegations against you think that some
of this would have been told or known to
somebody when they were putting this guy
forward well from what we can see from
the reporting there were lots of rumors
but nobody had come out and stated that
in fact this had happened to them I mean
they're the rumors were swirling around
according to the latest reporting it's
not only that he was seen in malls
talking to young women but even in local
schools and gym class is a talk on the
young women so that's kind of weird but
nothing that you would you know say oh
that's convincing or evidence or proof
Kimberly so I think the difference here
is that all of a sudden with calls to
specific women some of whom were Trump
voters and loyal Republicans some of the
women decided okay I will you know put
my name to this charge that's the big
difference that's what's made this so
explosive at this moment the second part
of it is that even while Sean Hannity
says that Roy Moore has 24 hours to put
forward some evidence that would
vindicate him you have Steve Bannon out
there on the other side who has not
withdrawn his support for Roy Moore and
you apparently have according to the
polls you know a very close race in
which evangelicals in the state really
like Roy Moore and the fact that he puts
God above all and including above our
Constitution which rankles me but
understand that's what apparently a
large number of people in Alabama
respect and why they want Roy Moore in
the Senate so this is a you have been
really one person left to speak but the
guy we thought we'd hear from today
President Trump does he say well I don't
know or does he say like Mitch McConnell
I believe the women and then what does
that mean they were thinking about
asking the governor kiv to delay the
December 12th election she says no so
far and then Mitch McConnell says if
he's elected well maybe we'll expel him
on an ethics charge
boy this is getting nasty okay all right
well the president declined to make a
statement today Greg so still just
giving a little bit of air to this and
room for Roy Moore and his team to try
to do something compelling what were
your thoughts on what they produce at
the conference well when he said it
takes time to work out these allegations
he's actually right you know and we
thought if this were in a court an
actual court you would
time to prepare for this but in the
court of public opinion with an election
you don't have the luxury you have to
make us you have to rush to judgment
because you have no other options so
that makes me feel bad I don't feel bad
for more I feel bad for the Alabama
voters who are having a hard time with
this because what we have we put this
whole issue this whole scandal and it's
the prison of two ideas he's either a
pervert or she's a liar
the fact is you know there are other
options involved here and one of them is
it was a hit piece and it's true the
bottom line is a voter can think that
this news dropping 40 days or what not
before an election is no coincidence
they can think that and still think he's
guilty but their anger their anger over
being screwed by the party or the media
is enough to make them think well screw
that I don't care so I have I you know
the allegations are serious I think the
post article was I mean there are names
there there are sources there this isn't
an it isn't some kind of anonymous thing
but I understand what voters look at
this they go like wow this is why now
why and then people will say well it's
because people are terrified of coming
out again you know and which makes sense
because he's a powerful guy you're right
to point out that they're not mutually
exclusive ya know he can be guilty of
these charges yeah and the Washington
Post piece can still be a political hit
job ya know that's the thing and that's
that's a gray area yeah it can be true
or some of it could not we don't know
yet because again they haven't had the
time to go ahead and actually it's flesh
out all of the details of it make sure
and see what's true what is it can I add
to that Jack it this is the irony of
this in the in the inner actual court
you have more freedom to defend yourself
in the court of public opinion you don't
sure we're gonna talk about this in the
next book